dieser kanten prozessor bricht alle
rekorde wir stehen damit vor einem
wirklich gigantischen technologiesprung
quantencomputer könnten die größten
probleme unserer zeit lösen spitzen
labors weltweit sind dabei diese systeme
zu entwickeln die sowohl forschung als
auch industrie revolutionieren werden
jetzt hat das technologieunternehmen ibm
einen neuartigen konnten prozessor
vorgestellt nicht mal supercomputer
können in simulieren und schon bald
werden quantencomputer praxistauglich
erste anwendung sind wohl in der
chemie-industrie möglich bis dahin
werden die quanten prozessoren
allerdings noch einmal deutlich
leistungsfähiger tricks zum science in
future gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
laut dem us amerikanischen
technologieunternehmen ibm könnte dieser
neue quanten prozessor zitat
quantencomputer in eine neue ära führen
der igel chip ist demnach mit
127 quantenbits der ersten prozesse auf
dem markt der die 100 cupid schallmauer
durchbricht überall auf der welt
forschen hochkarätige
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sowie unternehmen wie google und
microsoft an der entwicklung der
quantencomputer es herrscht ein
regelrechtes wettrennen um die
entwicklung überlegener konnten
computer- und das nicht umsonst denn
fachleute sind sich einig dass die
quanten technik die nächste industrielle
revolution ausmachen wird ein bmw
dahingehend jetzt den nächsten
meilenstein erreicht haben doch was kann
der igel chip wirklich und sind seine
leistungsdaten tatsächlich ein solch
enormer fortschritt wie weit sind wir in
sachen quantencomputer wirklich die
antworten auf all diese spannenden
fragen und noch viel mehr gibt es jetzt
bei pixum sa 10 14
ibm sagt zu dem neuen prozessor mit
eagle wird rechnerisches neuland
betreten und ein wichtiger meilenstein
auf dem weg zur praktischen quanten
berechnung gelegt miegel ist der nächste
schritt in einer technologischen
revolution in der geschichte des rechnet
laut des technologieunternehmens handelt
es sich bei dieser entwicklung um einen
entscheidenden meilenstein tatsächlich
könnten mit der hilfe von
quantencomputern die wirklich großen
probleme unserer zeit angegangen werden
so die hoffnung zahlreicher
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit vor allem in der industrie und
forschung die etwa in den bereichen
künstliche intelligenz oder big data
könnten quantencomputer für einen großen
sprung nach vorne sorgen dazu sagt der
forschungschef von ibm dario gil
quantencomputer haben das potenzial
nahezu jedem sektor zu verändern und das
wirklich in einem gigantischen maßstab
grundlage dafür ist die besondere art
und weise der kanten computer
informationen zu verarbeiten klassische
computer arbeiten mit witz die jeweils
nur zwei zustände annehmen können eins
und null also an und aus anders dagegen
bei den kranken computern sie basieren
auf den sogenannten quantenbits qubits
die beide werte gleichzeitig annehmen
theoretisch können sie sogar unendlich
viele zuständen dazwischen annehmen und
zwar gleichzeitig und so sind sie in der
lage so viele mögliche lösungen zur
selben zeit durch rechnungen zu können
oder anders gesagt in einem klassischen
computer handelte sich bei der kleinsten
recheneinheit und biz in einem
quantenphysikalischen system übernehmen
beispielsweise ionen also quantenbits
oder kurz kibiz diese aufgabe das ganze
ist ein teil der quantenwelt die
wissenschaft bereits seit vielen jahren
fasziniert das phänomen der
verschränkung erlaubt es den zustand von
teilchen atomen ionen oder photonen zu
koppeln ganz egal wie weit diese
voneinander entfernt sobald sich der
zustand des ein teilchens ändert gibt es
auch beim verschränken partner teilchen
einen zustand wechsel und genau das ist
die basis für viele super praktische
anwendung der quantenphysik und davon
ist der kranken computer nur eine
praktisch gesehen könnten kranken
computer tatsächlich die nächste
industrielle revolution auslösen das
hoffen zumindest zahlreiche fachleute
verschiedener wissenschaftsdisziplinen
sie könnten nicht nur in der
energiewirtschaft sondern auch in der
nationalelf wird lung wichtige aufgaben
übernehmen auch für berechnungen in der
logistik in der finanzwirtschaft oder im
bereich der datensicherheit könnten
quantencomputer einen schier
unglaublichen fortschritt ermöglicht in
einen quanten internet über das
gespeicherte information über große
entfernungen ausgetauscht werden könnte
sogar eine neue ära der kommunikation
einleiten es wäre komplett abhörsicher
jetzt hat das us amerikanische
technologieunternehmen ibm einen jahr
technologiesprung zu vermelden 2017
verfügten die ibm quanten chips canary
nur über fünf kumpels 28 googles
erreichen dann die falken serie anfang
des jahres 2020 und im herbst des
vergangenen jahres konnte das
hummingbird system des konzerns immerhin
schon 65 googles aufweisen der ersten
prozesse aus der igel generation von ibm
dagegen hat jetzt 127 jubels erreicht
wie die entwicklerinnen entwickler
mitteilen das muss man sich mal
vorstellen die zahl der möglichen
zustände von 127 jubels übersteigt damit
die anzahl der atome in allen menschen
auf der erde eine echte premiere denn
kein anderer quantencomputer hat bisher
mehr als 100 jubels erreicht ibm hat
damit beinahe eine verdoppelung
geschafft und das ist tatsächlich ein
großer erfolg igel erreicht somit eine
deutlich höhere rechenleistung als
android am computer klar denn cubes
können bei der gegenseitigen
verschränkung zahlreiche zustände
verkörpern je mehr klicks desto höher
die rechenleistung jedes dazu kommende
cupid verdoppelt die anzahl der
gleichzeitig darstellbaren zuständen
spricht ein cupid kann zwei zustände
gleichzeitig an dem zwei kübels
4384 16 5 32 64 128 256
521.000 24
8192 runde mal ab 16.000 mit dem
nächsten coup
32.000 64.000 128000
256.000 ja das ist exponentielles
wachstum bei 127 verdopplung ist es eben
eine zahl die höher ist als alle atome
in den menschen auf dieser erde und das
zeigt das unglaubliche rechen potenzial
eines einzigen prozesses um es mit
modernen supercomputern zu vergleichen
die enthalten tausende prozessoren und
ibm ist es nun nicht einmal mehr möglich
das system mit einem solchen super
computer zu simulieren und das nicht
einmal wenn man den schnellsten
supercomputer der welt einsetzen schon
im kommenden jahr will ibm einen könnten
computer entwickeln der mindestens 300
kübels erreicht solcher systeme könnten
dann mehr zustände ablesen als atome im
universum gibt ja das ist einfach nur
technisch gesehen bestehen der prozessor
empfangen computer igel nicht mehr nur
aus einer ebene die cubes befinden sich
auf einer eigenen ebene die teile und
leitung der mikrowellen schaltung aber
auf einer anderen bei dieser art von
aufbau hat sich ibm von klassischen cpu
s inspirieren lassen um die elektronik
und verkabelung zu reduzieren wird ein
gebündeltes auslese multiplexing genutzt
so wird nicht nur platz im mischung skat
gespart dadurch ist es auch nicht mehr
notwendig jedes cupid mit einem eigenen
satz von auslesung steuerelektronik
auszustatten ab 100 kwp es wäre das
sowieso eine fiese sperrige
angelegenheit übel selbst sind nicht
mehr in vier oder drei ecken angeordnet
sondern im wabenmuster in der
fachsprache ist von einer heavy hacks
topologie die rede laut des
technologiekonzerns hat das den vorteil
dass so die fehlerrate und die frequenz
kollision reduziert werden letztendlich
führen dass es zu einer deutlich höheren
praktischen leistungen konkrete angaben
dazu also zur fehlerrate machte ibm mich
dabei stellt dies eine kritische metrik
bei konnten computern da wäre wichtig um
das paket im gesamten zu bewerten ibm
äußert sich so dass nicht nur die anzahl
der cubes den fortschritt bestimmt
sondern eben auch die leistungsmerkmale
der geschwindigkeit und qualität auch
der theoretische physiker frank wilhelm
auch vom forschungszentrum jülich ist
dieser meinung er sagt in einem
interview mit tagesschau.de neben der
cube zahl ist im augenblick vor allem
die verringerung der fehlerrate der
entscheidenden parameter darüber und die
fortschritte auf diesem gebiet haben wir
hierbei geht es ums ganze im flugzeug ja
schon berichtet der link ist hier unter
mich denn keine frage auch
quantencomputer sind nicht vor fehlern
gefeit ganz im gegenteil fehler können
sich unter anderem dann einstreichen
werden ein krankenbett cupid ungewollt
seinen zustand ändert in einem
klassischen computer können solche
fehler korrigiert werden vergleichen
kann man das mit dem unerwünschten
schalten eines bits von null auf eins
übernehmen das herum ein bit kant
mehrfach kopiert werden um solche fehler
in einem gewöhnlichen computer zu
korrigieren denn die meisten kopien
beinhalten dann den richtigen wert sogar
dann wenn sich einzelne fehler
einschleichen in der quantenwelt ist das
ganz anders empfunden informationen
lassen sich nicht kopieren dazu der
experimentalphysiker rainer blatt wenn
wir in der zukunft wirklich nutzbare
kanten computer erreichen wollen
brauchen wir mehr kibiz mehr operation
um zuverlässige operation
quantencomputer basieren also auf den
vorteilen die quanten physikalische
phänomene wie überlagerung von
verschränkung mit sich bringt auf der
anderen seite sind diese auch enorm
anfällig nicht nur umwelt anschlüsse
sondern auch störungen können zu fehlern
in der berechnung führen heisst also im
klartext die fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit
muss so klein werden dass alle tubes
auch wirklich nutzbar sind
funktionierende quantencomputer könnten
möglicherweise also erst in zehn jahren
wirklich marktreif sein so die prognose
zahlreiche fachleute dazu wilhelm auch
ich gehe davon aus dass wir in fünf bis
zehn jahren prozesse in der chemischen
industrie haben werden die mit hilfe von
quantencomputern entwickelt wurden doch
dafür müsse zunächst der fehler um den
faktor 10 reduziert werden und auch die
tube zahl müsste noch einmal
verzehnfacht werden erst ab tausenden
von sauberen cubes würde die sache
spannend so frank will immer möglichst
fehlerfreies rechner ist also eines der
großen ziele die fehlerquote bei googles
experiment von zwei jahren 2009/10 lag
bei 0,5 prozent ein forschungsteam von
google hatte damals die überlegenheit
von quantencomputern gegenüber den
schnellsten klassischen computer
nachgewiesen demnach brauchte der konten
prozessor von google für die berechnung
einer aufgabe 2/100 sekunden für die ein
klassischer computer also supercomputer
10.000 jahre benötigt hätte war google
wurde damit die sogenannte quanten
überlegenheit erreicht allerdings mit
einer aufgabe die ganz speziell für
diesen quantencomputer entwickelt worden
bauen in diesem video also hier berichte
ich über die fortschritte bei der
fehlerkorrektur von quanten rechnern
quantencomputer endlich marktreif fehler
können jetzt weg gewählt werden also
unbedingt anklicken anschauen abonnieren
wenn ihr mehr über das thema kanten
computer wissen wollt ansonsten bestand
bleibt dran